nach donald trump sieg über hillary
clinton nehmen berichtet referendum und
der ausbreitung der wall street in halb
europa sahen viele die französische
präsidentschaftswahl 2017 als letzte
bastion gegen populismus und für
menschlichkeit und toleranz
jetzt fünf jahre später wiederholt sich
diese geschichte kurz vor den
französischen präsidentschaftswahlen
verweisen es viele kandidaten und
journalisten auf die große geschichte
des landes und sein umfassendes
engagement für die menschenrechte
inmitten der düsteren denner stimmung
aufstrebenden imperialismus und
populismus steht ein strahlendes
leuchtfeuer für menschlichkeit
wissenschaft kunst und alle guten seiten
europas der eifel therme naja zumindest
meinen dass frankreichs eigene politiker
natürlich ist die realität da etwas
anders und viel weniger episch denn wie
general de gaulle bereits sagte
frankreich kann nicht frankreich sein
wenn es nicht groß ist koste es was es
wolle
denn eines ist klar frankreichs
außenpolitik ist nicht gerade sagen wir
mal unkompliziert es stellt sich also
die durchaus berechtigte frage war
frankreich wirklich schon immer der
leuchtturm der demokratie für dänische
politik erhalten warum werden die
handlungen frankreichs außerhalb
frankreich so anders gesehen als es die
franzosen selbst im eigenen land tun
liebe visual politik fans ich kann euch
schon jetzt verraten dass dieses video
ein bisschen anders sein wird als unsere
üblichen zum anlass der bevorstehenden
präsidentschaftswahl in der republik
werden wir uns auf einige der grössten
skandale konzentrieren die frankreich
jede menge internationale kritik und
rückschläge eingebracht haben das ist
die andere die dunkle seite der front
nation also schnallt euch an wir gehen
auf eine ganz besondere tour de france
oder eher gesagt tour de farce
[Applaus]
[Musik]
staatsstreiche unterdrückung kampagnen
entführungen und attentate frankreichs
außenpolitik gründet sich nicht immer
auf samstag diplomatie dialog und dem
freien austausch von meinungen heute
werfen wir daher einen blick auf einige
der größten internationalen skandale in
welche die französische republik
angeblich verwickelt war skandale die
viele verdächtigungen
verschwörungstheorien und ressentiments
geschürt haben einige davon werden von
paris kategorisch abgestritten obwohl es
viele gründe gibt diese dementis
selbstzweifel so ziehen auf der anderen
seite gibt es einige skandale die hinter
vorgehaltener hand sogar zugegeben
werden so gesehen halte ich es für das
beste wenn wir jetzt einige von ihnen
ans licht bringen und es dir was der
erste führt uns gleich ins ferne
südamerika
[Musik]
operation condor
in den 1970 er jahren war ein großer
teil südamerikas unter der kontrolle
diktatorische regimes tiere länder mit
eiserner faust regiert wir sprechen hier
insbesondere von brasilien argentinien
chile paraguay und bolivien und uruguay
und am 28 november
1975 starteten die regierungen dieser
länder mit ausnahme von brasilien was es
aber nicht daran hinderte sich aktiv zu
beteiligen offiziell die sogenannte
operation condor es handelte sich um
nichts geringeres als eine kampagne der
politischen unterdrückung und des
staates terrorismus zur verfolgung der
politischen opposition insbesondere der
linken opposition wir sprechen hier von
einer gezielten und minutiös
konzertierten unterdrückung kampagne an
der sich die meisten regierungen
südamerikas beteiligten und bei welcher
zahlreiche politische gegner ermordet
wurden der terror steckte über den süden
der neuen welt hinweg und tat dies mit
starker unterstützung der vereinigten
staaten und der sharrod ford jimmy
carter und ronald reagan
zehntausende von irregulären
verhaftungen entführungen und
auslieferungen wurden über einen
zeitraum von mehr als zehn jahren
durchgeführt folter war weit verbreitet
und einige schätzungen gehen davon aus
dass die operation condor mehr als
60.000 menschen ihr leben kostete zu den
opfern gehörten linke guerilla es aber
auch politischen dissidenten
gewerkschaftsführer studenten
intellektuelle lehrer priester und
bauern
nun ja aus dem geschichtsunterricht
wisst ihr es vielleicht dass die suite
amerikanischen regierungen diesen plan
vor allem mit der unterstützung der usa
durchgezogen haben das zumindest ist die
offizielle story aber wartet noch einen
moment wenn das ist vielleicht nicht die
ganze wahrheit vor allem dann nicht wenn
die über argentinien und chile sprechen
es geht mir nicht um folgendes einige
originaldokumente des französischen
aussenministeriums scheint eine
vereinbarung zwischen paris und buenos
aires aus den jahren 1959 zu legen und
diese besagen dass in argentinien eine
ständige militärmissionen französische
offiziere eingerichtet werden soll die
zuvor im algerienkrieg gekämpft hatten
es wird auch vermutet dass die regierung
von präsidentin christa aktiv und
heimlich mit der wieder nach unter in
argentinien und dem regime von augusto
pinochet in chile zusammengearbeitet hat
auf diese weise hätten die franzosen die
geheimdienste der argentinischen
diktatur geschult einschließlich
professionelle ausbildung in folter
techniken und nicht nur das die von
isabel peron unterzeichneten
vernichtungs dekrete scheinen von
früheren französischen dokumenten
inspiriert worden zu sein
general reynaldo bignone der 1982 zum
präsidenten der argentinischen
militärjunta ernannt wurde bekundete
höchstselbst dass der schlachtplan des
krude tat er das argentinische militär
1976 an die macht brachte von
frankreichs eigenen erfahrungen in
algerien inspiriert war
viele jahre später im jahr 2003
forderten die abgeordneten der
französischen grünen die einsetzung
eines parlamentarischen
untersuchungsausschusses die frankreichs
rolle bei der aktiven unterstützung von
militärregimes in südamerika untersuchen
sollte ein ausschuss der total in die
hose ging weil der ausschuss leiter
roller blüm sich weigerte wichtige
zeugenaussagen zu lassen
wir können also festhalten die
französische regierung als war aktiv
bestritten eine rolle bei der operation
condor gespielt zu haben aber es gibt
reihenweise gründe dafür diese
behauptung anzuzweifeln 2007 begründete
der argentinische admiral luis maria
mandy ja vor gericht dass der
französische geheimdienst an der
entführung und ermordung von zwei
französischen neuen im land der gauchos
beteiligt war und das ist nur ein
beispiel von vielen sicher ist aber dass
es trotz ständiger london seitens paris
so scheint als häuften sich die beweise
aber wisst ihr was wir haben gerade erst
angefangen denn wenn es ein gebiet gibt
auf dem die diplomatie france es
wirklich regiert dann ist das eindeutig
afrika aufgepasst
[Musik]
der liebeskampf blass des gallischen
hahns
es sind nun schon mehr als 60 lange
jahre vergangen seit die französischen
kolonien in afrika in ihrer
unabhängigkeit entlassen wurden oder
sich diese erkämpfen mussten trotzdem
bleibt die rolle der französischen
nation auf dem afrikanischen kontinent
so stark dass sie sogar ihren eigenen
namen hat france afrique dieses fonds
afrique ist ein konzept das versucht
zwei umstände miteinander zu verbinden
den politischen einfluss frankreichs und
in versteckten einfluss der verborgenen
netzwerke voller korruption und
zwielichtiger geschäfte die weiterhin
zwischen dem alten und pere und seinen
emanzipierten kolonien bestehen oder
vielmehr zwischen frankreich und jenen
eliten welche ihre ehemaligen kolonien
kontrollieren über das verheerende
wirkung der aggression in der sahel zone
haben wir ja bereits ein video gedreht
das ich euch hinter den oben rechts und
in der beschreibung unten verlinkten
werden falls euch dieses thema
interessiert und wir dieses video noch
nicht gesehen habt solltet ihr das
unbedingt nachholen ach ja und falls sie
unseren kanal noch nicht abonniert habt
dann jetzt aber schnell und bietet das
glück nicht vergessen und keines unserer
informativen videos mehr zu verpassen
ich danke euch von ganzem herzen aber
nun weiter im text denn wenn es eine
sache gibt die für die französische
regierung immer klar war dann ist es
ihre entschlossenheit frankreichs
internationalen einfluss zu bewahren und
auch wenn die noch jungen wirtschaftlich
ganz und gar nicht mehr grund ist
weiterhin als globale supermacht zu
gelten und afrika spielt in dieser
strategie eine schlüsselrolle
obwohl bereits sechs jahrzehnte
vergangen sind sind frankreichs präsenz
einfluss und macht in der region immer
noch schlicht und ergreifend enorm diese
position wurde während des kalten
krieges von den usa selbst aktiv
unterstützt und warum weil frankreich
während des kalten kriegs zur
speerspitze wurde es für bastion des
westens gegen sowjetischen einfluss in
der region eine rolle die sich paris
sehr aber auch wirklich sehr zu herzen
genommen hat um euch eine vorstellung
davon zu geben frankreich hat in afrika
so stark interveniert das ist so 1960
bis mitte der 1990 er jahre im
durchschnitt eine militärische
intervention pro jahr durchgeführt hat
ja ihr habt ganz richtig gehört mit
durchschnitt eine militärintervention
pro jahr das lässt die usa unter george
bush praktisch wie blutige anfänger in
sachen internationale intervention ismus
dastehen
[Musik]
frank reichert auf dem afrikanischen
kontinent so gut wie alles hinter sich
von der klassischen intervention zum
schutz französische bürger über die
niederschlagung von rebellionen über die
verhinderung von staatsstreichen bis hin
zur unterstützung von staatsstreichen
paris hat noch nicht einmal davor
zurückgeschreckt präsidenten zu
beseitigen die eine bedrohung für ihre
pläne darstellten hier zum beispiel ist
eine liste afrikanischer präsidenten an
deren liquidierung frankreich beteiligt
gewesen sein soll
okay stimmt schon die meisten von ihnen
waren vielleicht richtige tor an aber
das gibt euch einmal eine ungefähre
vorstellung davon was frankreich in der
region alles angestellt hat und man kann
auch nicht sagen dass diese
einmischungen zu besonders guten
ergebnissen geführt hätte abgesehen von
frankreichs eigenen interessen versteht
sich so viel gerede über die chinesen in
afrika aber dann st
um diese strategie umzusetzen spielten
nicht einig 203 französische
geheimdienste eine sehr aktive rolle bei
der organisation von staatsstreichen und
der bereinigung unbequemer oder
feindlicher führer
der auswärtige nachrichten und
spionageabwehr tigges kürbis die
dokumentation am exterieur die
generaldirektion für äußere sicherheit
der usa und die direktion der
territorialen überwachung dst und das
ist noch nicht alles tatsache ist
nämlich dass wir noch viele weitere
beispiele für äußerst kontroverse
aktionen in der geschichte der
französischen außenpolitik finden können
da wäre zum beispiel das berüchtigte
angola geld ein riesiger politischer
skandal im zusammenhang mit den geheimen
verkauf und der lieferung von waffen an
die angolanische regierung in den 1990
er jahren als skandal in dem viele der
hochrangigsten persönlichkeiten der
französischen politik verwickelt waren
vielleicht sagen wir ja die schillernden
namen francois mitterrand oder jacques
chirac etwas ein noch schlimmerer fall
ist die ermordung von berna borel im
jahr 1995 einem in djibouti
stationierten französischen
friedensrichter der allem anschein nach
von der ägyptischen regierung selbst
ermordet wurde und könnt ihr euch
folgendes vorstellen dass damals in
frankreichs interesse lag die
beziehungen zu diesem afrikanischen land
weiter zu pflegen deutet alles darauf
hin dass frankreich die regierung tut
dies bei der vorbereitung auf die
verteidigung vor gericht beriet und er
gleichzeitig wichtige informationen über
die laufenden polizeilichen ermittlungen
zu spielte dh die französische regierung
hinter trieb die verfolgung und
verurteilung der mörder ihres eigenen
friedensrichters was das ganze klingt so
unglaublich die eine krude
verschwörungstheorie um die regierung
eines demokratischen landes zu
beschmutzen
[Musik]
ja genau das dachten damals vielleicht
auch manche aber jetzt halt dich fest am
ende erwies sich dieser ganze schmutz
dann doch als wahr und frankreich wurde
für diese ganze angelegenheit sogar
höchstinstanzlich verurteilt zunächst
2015 vom europäischen gerichtshof für
menschenrechte und später im jahr 2020
von einem pariser gericht als frankreich
sich in die ermittlungen ein gemischt
und druck auf die anwälte der witwe von
bernar borel ausgeübt hatte
und wir wissen ja nur zu gut was er
immer zu hören bekommen gerechtigkeit
und menschenrechte stehe an erster
stelle
blablabla wer's glaubt wird selig dass
interventionen manchmal sehr schlecht
enden können wenn sie in büros geplant
werden wie tausende kilometer entfernt
sind beweist ein weiterer nicht sehr
bekannter dafür aber sehr gut
dokumentierter fall der von ruanda ich
spreche davon dass frankreich auf eine
gewisse art und weise genau die
regierung unterstützt hat welche den
völkermord von 1994 beging frankreich
hat nämlich der hutu regierung aktiv
unter die arme gegriffen indem es die
hutu-milizen nur kurz vor beginn des
großen abschlachten der tutsi-minderheit
mit waffen und militärische ausbildung
versorgt obwohl es klar war was sie
damit vorhatten waffen und unterstützung
welche die hutu nur kurz darauf nutzten
um innerhalb weniger monate zwischen
einer halben und einer million tutsi zu
massakrieren aber afrika ist nicht der
einzige schauplatz an dem frankreich mit
heftigen kontroversen konfrontiert war
und noch immer ist ein ganz aktuelles
beispiel ist der krieg im jemen
[Musik]
de klerk panzergranaten mehr als 2009
flugzeuge probe radare gepanzerte aravis
transportflugzeuge software hubschrauber
die lafayette fregatte alma keine
raketen corbett und cesar geschützt dies
ist nur ein teil der langen liste von
französischer militärausrüstung die von
saudi arabien im jemen krieg eingesetzt
wird und trotz der wiederholten
öffentlichen leugnungen der
französischen regierung deutet alles
darauf hin dass frankreich seinen waffen
katalog für diesen weit geöffnet hat um
aus diesen krieg maximalen profit zu
schlagen
ein krieg wohlgemerkt in denen die
sicherheit der zivilbevölkerung nie eine
priorität war und das ist noch nicht
alles vieles deutet darauf hin dass
frankreich auch die saudische armee aus
gibt es und logistisch unterstützt habe
obwohl es die öffentlich wieder einmal
abstreitet es gibt ziemlich glaubwürdige
berichte dass frankreich sogar so weit
gehen unter größter geheimhaltung
französische spezialkräfte im jemen
einzusetzen sechzehnter juni 2018
luftiger rauch französische
spezialkräfte vor ort im jemen kurz
gesagt wir können noch viele weitere
fälle aufzählen
[Musik]
bis die reine großteil der durch der
stadt konzentriert sich zwar auf die
skandale und angeblichen exzesse von
ländern wie den usa oder saudi arabien
und das oft auch zu recht wir berichten
ja auch drüber aber auch auf unserem
alten kontinent in direkter
nachbarschaft gibt es reichlich
kontroversen und sogar verbrechen und im
besonderen fall frankreichs ist ist dem
land gelungen seinen status als eines
der einflussreichsten länder in globalen
angelegenheiten aufrechterhalten obwohl
es sagen wir mal nicht immer transparenz
richtigkeit und die menschenrechte
geachtet und gefördert hat ja seinen
einfluss konnte es aufrecht erhalten und
machen wir uns nichts vor auch die wie
geschmiert laufenden geschäfte sondern
sehr bedeutenden militärindustrie dass
meine lieben zuschauer ist der wahre
preis für frankreichs nationale kongress
und selbst all die ungeheuerlichkeiten
die wir euch in diesem video präsentiert
haben sind nur ein kleiner ausschnitt
der breiten und sehr lange blutspur des
modernen französischen imperialismus wir
könnten viele weitere eigenständige
videos füllen mit themen wie dem
rücksichtslosen atomwaffenprogramm der
grund nation welche
110.000 bewohner des südpazifik mit 193
atombombenexplosion radioaktiv verseucht
hat die hinterhältige versenkung des
greenpeace schiffes rainbow warrior und
und und aber kommt zeit und geld kommen
auch viele neue interessante videos für
euch vergesst also bitte nicht uns auch
mit einer kleinen spende zu unterstützen
damit unser projekt weitergehen kann den
link findet ihr unten in der
beschreibung zu diesem video und jetzt
seid ihr erstmal mit eurer eigenen
meinung an der reihe was haltet ihr von
frankreichs außenpolitik wie bewertet
ihr seine rolle in afrika und glaubt ihr
dass die verfolgung nationale interessen
und vorteile verschiedenster art
frankreichs interventionen rechtfertigt
welche von frankreichs weiteren
missetaten sollte eurer meinung nach in
einem eigenen video behandeln also ab
damit in die kommentare sektion ich
hoffe wir immer dass euch dieses video
gefallen hat was ja gibt uns mit deinen
leisten und folgen und vergesst nicht
das abo mit glücklichen und keines
unserer videos mehr zu verpassen was gut
und bis bald
[Musik]